Mortal Kombat's fatalities you know them
you love them
these over-the-top finishing moves are
what helped to propel the success of the
series but what about the other
finishing moves you know the friendships
let's take a look back at the silly side
of MORTAL KOMBAT history with the
evolution of this unique finishing move
introduced in Mortal Kombat 2 the
short-lived friendship finishers were
created as a sarcastic response to the
backlash against the grotesque violence
of the first game instead of brutally
decapitating your opponent or
uppercutting them down into a bed of
spikes you could end the match by
signing an autograph as Johnny Cage
kicking a football as Sindel or doing
the Cyrax dance but these
family-friendly finishes didn't replace
the classic fatalities in fact more than
double the amount of fatalities were
added in Mortal Kombat 2 even amidst the
1993 congressional hearings against
video game violence
Mortal Kombat was poking fun at its
cynics more finishes such as vibe a
letí's animality x' and brutalities were
introduced over the next few titles
however after the release of Mortal
Kombat trilogy in 1996 friendships were
removed to make way for Mortal Kombat
fours grittier new 3d visuals we
wouldn't see another friendship for 24
years at least until he recently
announced Mortal Kombat 11 aftermath
expansion while not the spiciest way to
finish off an opponent friendships left
their mark on the Mortal Kombat universe
with all the disgustingly creative
fatalities throughout the years it'll be
interesting to see what other clever
friendships we'll see down the road from
Mortal Kombat 11 and beyond
share your favorite friendship in the
comments below and for future Mortal
Kombat coverage keep it right here on
GameSpot
[Music]
you